when you pass a magnet over a wire it
induces a current in that wire if you
run alternately if you run a current
through a wire it creates an
electromagnetic field so if you have a
whole bunch of coils and you start
passing some magnets over them which are
on this vehicle and you design this all
correctly it'll actually start lifting
the vehicle off there's a repulsion and
it's stable so now what happens if you
lose the power to propel the vehicle you
do not lose the mag magnetic levitation
the passive magnetic levitation so it's
super safe with seven pounds of lithium
polymer backup batteries and our
vehicles say we're going 100 miles an
hour and we lose all grid power we will
we can still go three miles and we
should have stations every mile apart so
there's a big safety factor with passive
maglev and again the it's always had to
be some kind of maglev because we do not
want all the maintenance costs
associated with gears and a little tires
wearing out and we want the high speed
capability
like the transrapid maglev train that
goes what I think 300 miles an hour in
Beijing for a short distance first one
if they lose power they lose their
levitation you'd come to a screeching
halt they have to have all kind of like
computer uninterruptedly that never
never happens and you know you can
design it however that is a huge train
very expensive just ridiculously
expensive pretty fast and very high
maintenance that because their maglev is
so critical in tolerance they have to
keep the that track super aligned
properly where ours is very tolerant and
our vehicles are small so everything is
cheap in comparison a lot less expensive
that thing is probably weighs a million
pounds in our little vehicles at gross
wait'll you know weigh 750 pounds it's
just we have a continuous stream of
vehicles and they have the one big
vehicle so they are flying if you want
to call it flying every what half hour
in our case if they're going 300 miles
an hour in our case you'd get there boom
you'd be on board and going so you'd
probably get there just as quick on
under 50 miles an hour if we replaced or
put it side-by-side with the Beijing's
transrapid system
a sky chan is a much cheaper option or
compared to light rail because we're
light ins lighter smaller faster we can
move more people an hour use a lot less
energy a lot less or no land basically
we can pop skytrain onto sidewalks where
they have to their 60 70 million a mile
a lot of that is just buying up land
valuable land we don't need to do that
we we just need a two foot post every
every so many feet to build our system
and we can attach it to buildings it's
the advantage of going small and they
can carry so many people but even if
they're coming by once every five
minutes or once every three minutes once
you have a continuous system with
stations convenience stations everywhere
you can carry a lot more people per hour
it's a it's a very close to the
automobile you know why have we started
loving the automobile because we can get
places faster cheaper more conveniently
unfortunately the the fossil fuels
everyone's starting to hate fossil fuels
is just like boy back in the original
days of this country the Jamestown
Colony was ready to go back to England
and then all of a sudden they got a
product that people would buy guess what
that was tobacco and now tobacco is an
evil product and fossil fuels are going
that same way and that was a second
product that really made this country
world war two and everything and all the
technology based on fossil fuel but now
we're becoming more and more aware of
all the total disadvantages of it and
it's getting to be like an evil thing it
isn't but we will with our little brains
figure out how to get around it and
skytran is one good way to do that
you